[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact the Shearer of
vastness of space is truly
incomprehensible to the human brain
here's one example back in 1996 for 10
days astronomers pointed the Hubble
telescope into a part of the sky close
to the Big Dipper that seemed utterly
empty a little patch they focused on was
no bigger than a grain of rice held out
at arm's length
still they discovered 3,000 galaxies
came into focus producing one of the
most profound and humbling images of all
human history every single smear and dot
was an entire galaxy
that's a fiery pinwheel of light each
containing hundreds of billions of stars
not even counting how many planets there
might be then between 2004 and 2014
using much improved equipment they did
it again this time they pointed the
telescope towards an empty spot in the
constellation Orion for over a period of
nine years over ten thousand galaxies
appeared in that speck of space known as
the Ultra Deep Field this is the
farthest we've ever seen into the
universe but as if that wasn't
mind-boggling enough astronomers now
estimate that this vast universe that we
see is really only just quarter percent
of what's out there the immensity of
space is mind-boggling yet the Bible
says that God counts all the stars and
has a name for each one stay with his
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 heard that
we've got people that are calling in
from Australia and people listening from
Italy and different parts of the world
but before we get into our program
tonight we always begin with a word of
Prayer loving Lord we just thank you
again for the blessings of life we thank
you for the sacrifice of Jesus his death
and his resurrection that reminds us you
are a Living God that you ever lived to
make intercession for us at the right
hand of the Father and Lord we're
thankful for the promise that though
these bodies grow old and die we don't
need to fear we will be given glorious
bodies even like yours bless with that
encouragement for all listening be with
us in our program tonight we pray in
Jesus name Amen
well I started with an amazing fact
dealing with some of the photographs
they've taken in deep space
and I've seen that picture many times on
my universe of the Ultra Deep Field
where you see ten thousand galaxies in
one they estimate in one photograph and
each galaxy to those dots is a galaxy
with hundreds of billions of stars and
that was just a little piece of sky as
big as a grain of rice held out at arm's
length you think about how immense the
universe was must be and God made all of
that and then the Bible says you know
not only does the number the hairs of
her head it says he knows all the stars
he calls them all by name he knows every
detail of your life friends but how much
could can we know about God you know the
Bible says that he is past finding out
Isaiah tells us as the heavens are high
above the earth so are his ways above
our ways but we can know what is
revealed in his word now God is what he
is the three persons is who they are and
God is composed of three persons of the
Father Son and Holy Spirit we sometimes
uses her term Trinity the word Trinity
is not the Bible but the word
Incarnation is not in the Bible and
millennium is not the Bible indeed the
word Bible is not in the Bible and so
these are words that we use to explain
teachings but the understanding of God
you know Jesus said baptize in the name
of the Father Son and Holy Spirit and
there at the baptism of Jesus God said
this is my beloved Son God the Spirit
was coming down we see especially in the
New Testament the fullness of the
plurality of God now the Bible says
there's one God and that's because one
in the hueber mine means a United unit
but God in the beginning said let us
make man in our image
God said a man and woman get married
they become one flesh and jesus prayed
the 12 apostles john 17 might be one now
there's a lot of mysteries about God and
we're on holy ground but there are some
things revealed we can't understand and
if you'd like to better
in this subject of the Trinity we have a
free offer for you
you can just call the resource number
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and ask for the
free book on the Trinity in fact if
you'd like to read it right now so many
people download PDFs and books we've
made it available for free if you go to
the amazing facts website simply amazing
facts dot o-r-g you can read and/or
download it there all right with that
friends we're going to go to the phones
and we're starting out talking to Sarah
Sarah you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi pastor Doug alright
thank you for calling thank you yeah my
question is I had this lady or I know
this lady who she loved God she was very
involved in her church she was a
chaplain
I also know that she dealt a lot with
depression and she actually ended up
taking her own life and afterward the
discussion was you know I know that she
loved God is you know and people said
well we'll see her in heaven and now
that people are well you know suicide is
a sin and so I'm just wondering what
your thoughts are on that
you know it is a tough question because
I think we need to be careful to be
honest and be gentle we need to be
honest and tell people that suicide is a
sin because what other person's thinking
of it and you say oh yeah you can you
can be a Christian just murder yourself
I mean murder is a sin but we've got to
stop short of saying those who commit
suicide are all lost just technically
you could argue Simpson killed himself
and Hebrews said he'll be in heaven his
life was something of a sacrifice at the
end he I think they may have been
getting ready to kill him and he knew
that so you know and when a soldier
sacrifices himself on the battlefield it
could be called a suicide if he jumps on
a hand grenade but he's doing it to save
others so you see what I'm saying
there's there's a balance I did a
funeral for a young lady that got very
discouraged struggle with oppression
took sleeping pills realize what she had
done and then
called 911 please save me I just took
pills to kill myself they came they
couldn't resuscitate her so who's to say
in the last hours of her life for a
moment said she didn't repent and and
you know how can we say we don't know
what's going on in their mind some
people I know have been godly Christians
all their life in their final illness
they're medicated they're not thinking
clear and they've taken their life so
we've got to be careful not to tell
people there's no hope but at the same
time we've got to tell people that if
you're you thinking of suicide as a way
to ease your problems in most cases it
occurs you into a permanently bad
situation you know what I mean yeah so
yeah it's I think it's dangerous
business now going to the Bible I can
think of a couple of cases of suicides 3
in the Bible well let me see I hit a
foul hung himself a Judas hung himself
and both of them had just betrayed
friends grew Judas it says Satan entered
him he grieved away the Holy Spirit Saul
fell on his sword after he grieved away
the Holy Spirit the examples in the
Bible of suicide are not encouraging
with the exception of Sampson so I'd
strongly advise against it but we need
to stop short of saying that a suicide
is automatically lost we don't know
mm-hmm so hopefully that helps a little
it's a tough question hey thank you so
much appreciate that Sarah and with that
we're gonna move on talk next to someone
who's calling an anonymous caller I
thought maybe it's Steve Kansas City is
that you Steve yes it's me
hey thanks I pastor Doug I really
appreciate your show I was listening to
an older pre-recorded show on Casey
Excel and I was wondering about the
microchip there was one in a 25 years
ago in a baby and one in a woman's hand
so she could wave her wand and then
charge her her purchase I was wondering
if that was a physical manifestation
because it's like we know that you have
to have a number to buy and sell at the
end time was that the physical
manifestation of a spirit
cool event I know that your head and
your hand have to be like linking
towards the B system and giving into it
we're looking towards the B system and
just wondering if that's our they are
the spiritual and the physical tied in
that manner well there could be now let
me just clarify and make a distinction
here the final law of the B says those
who do not worship will be killed before
it gets to that point it talks about
they cannot buy or sell the beast power
will use some mechanism or technology to
control buying and selling but that
technology is not the mark it could they
have you know an RFD implant under the
skin while they're doing that now with
businesses I mean all kinds of people
are doing that but we've got to be
careful I remember when the bar code
first came out all my friends said don't
buy anything with the bar code it's the
mark of the beast well I think they all
starve since then and then you know
credit cards and the magnetic strip and
other people said that is the market the
peace because it's in your hand and RFD
cards IR the inserts I would really hate
to do that but the mark in the hand it
in the forehead let me read you
something Deuteronomy chapter 6 and if
you go to verse 6 Deuteronomy 6 6 he
says these words I command you today
shall be in your heart now they had just
given the Ten Commandments in
Deuteronomy 5 you'll teach them
diligently to your children you'll talk
of them when you sit in your house when
you walk by the way when you lay down
your eyes let my kitchen this part Steve
you bind them as a sign on your hand and
they will be frontlets between your eyes
on your hand in between your eyes the
saved are gonna have the seal of God in
their forehead right it's not a computer
chip they got the law of God between
their eyes the loss also have something
in their hand in between their eyes that
means in your actions Isaiah says evil
was in their hand well it doesn't mean
you're holding a ball of evil it means
their actions in that forehead means in
your thoughts in your worship when a
person chooses to obey the laws of the
Beast and they bow down to the image
instead of a
of God they're getting it in their hand
or their forehead the buying and selling
could be controlled with an RF D insert
or magnetic strip or something like that
so that's where they might be tied
together but let's be careful not to
think that you know if a person gets a
credit card or if somebody with diabetes
gets this little implant under usually
between the thumb and the forefinger
that means they've got the mark of the
beast I don't really see that in the
Bible hey can I send you a free lesson
on that subject if you just go to the
amazing facts website we got a lesson
called the mark of the beast I've got a
whole sermon I preached there on YouTube
but see if you can also call 808 three
five six seven four seven ask for our
lesson on the mark of the beast and
thank you very much for calling talking
next to Stephanie in Austin Stephanie
you're on the air with Bible answers
live hello hi thank you for calling from
Austin Texas is that right that's
correct
and your question my question is I
recently was telling someone about the
story of Job and and I was talking to
them and telling them about you know how
God and Satan we're talking about joband
and how God allowed Satan to take away
everything except he couldn't kill him
and so in telling and retelling the
story of Job this person that I was
talking to just saw terrible qualities
of God and and it actually did some
damage to their faith and I would just
really love to be able to go back and
tell them because I kept saying that
there are so many more lessons and I
kept telling them what those lessons
were and they just couldn't get past the
idea of God allowing these things to
happen to an innocent person well that
you know it's gonna be a struggle to try
to help them understand it is true that
God withdrew his protection from job he
allowed job to be tested God did not
cause the calamity God just withdrew his
protection the devil said the only
reason that job is serving you
you bless them take away the blessings
he'll curse you now keep in mind the
sufferings of job may have lasted a few
weeks God then restored everything to
job twice as much afterward and so
sometimes we go through a valley in
order to get to a mountain and so they
need to focus on how God blessed job
even more afterward so here's a man who
lives nearly 200 years according to the
Bible and out of the two hundred years
he's got a few weeks of severe suffering
what is that compared to 200 years and
eternal life so I hope that their
perspective will allow that yes
sometimes God does allow us this effort
does that person know that God allowed
his son to suffer that we might be saved
yes and I did tell them you know that
you know that this was kind of you know
God and Jesus was a sinless person and
all these things we fail him so that we
could eventually end up in heaven again
with him and you know but they just
could not get over the fat one part and
I've kept saying there's so many there's
so much more to the story and I was just
wish you would open your heart and
listen but they couldn't get past that
you know that God allowed that to happen
yeah the it's important that they do get
past that because what they're doing is
they're putting themselves in the
position to go through some of the
trials of job if they don't get past
that you know I've got a series I just
did a series for 12 weeks on the book of
Job and if you go to youtube and you
type in Doug Batchelor your book of Job
you'll probably see a number of the
studies I did there during a Sabbath
School class and I go into great detail
on there hey thank you so much for your
call Stephanie and I'm gonna talk next -
let me see line four is this Patrick
Patrick you're on the air with Bible
answers live mr. Doug good thank you for
calling so my question is if God told
Adam a need to be approved fuller
multiply and there were the only beings
on the earth at the time did they most
did they
multiplied as far as there's a kid did
he multiply with their siblings and so
in essence did God allow incest and this
other God a pool of incest back in and
is he a pleaded incest today
alright good question well Adam and Eve
have an interesting relationship you
could say Adam and Eve our brother and
sister in the sense that they both came
from the same parents but it's a little
even weirder than that in that Eve came
from Adam's rib but the children of Adam
and Eve the boys probably married their
sisters right and say probably I know
they did keep in mind the reason that it
is wrong in our day and age for brothers
and sisters to intermarry is because
you'll have all kinds of genetic defects
and weakness when you do that there's a
lot of problems with different tribes
and peoples or some diseases that are
only exclusive to people living on
Islands or there's certain you know I'm
half Jewish but there's some diseases
only Jews get because they they stayed
marrying just Jews for so many centuries
that they there are some genetic
weaknesses that happen there there are
certain diseases that only
african-americans get are there more
prevalent and so genetic vitality is the
reason that you're especially not
supposed to marry close to the family
tree but Adam I'm sorry
Abraham married his sister Sarah's
half-sister anyways Sarah Isaac married
his first cousin Jacob married his first
cousin by the time you get to Moses
Moses said you're not to marry your near
of kin so that there would be genetic
vitality and because the Israelites
occasionally married with other people
that converted like Ruth became a
Moabite us and Rahab who was a Canaanite
became I'm sorry the Moabite as Ruth
became a Jew a Rahab a Canaanite became
a Jew they were getting an influx of
healthy genes so you know that's the
main reason in the beginning when man's
genes were perfect as they came from God
he helped Cain and Abel and Seth they
all married sisters so I know that
sounds strange but that's the way it was
back then
hey thank you very much appreciate your
question
and you know I do have a book that talks
a little about that you can get it's
called who are the sons of God and
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven asked for the book who are the
sons of God Patrick and thank you for
your call with that we're gonna go to
our next caller Christopher who is
calling with a question Christopher
you're on the air from Hampton Kentucky
hey Dad my question was who is the two
witnesses in Revelation and I was a
little bit confused on that when I was
reading it all right well when you read
in Revelation chapter 11 it talks about
these two witnesses and it's a prophecy
about an all-out war that came against
the Word of God the Word of God are the
two witnesses sometimes the Word of God
is portrayed as Moses and Elijah because
Moses represents the law and Elijah
represents the prophets the Old
Testament ends by saying remember the
law of Moses this is Malachi chapter for
behold I send you Elijah the prophet
then you turn into the New Testament
Moses and Elijah appeared to Jesus and
Jesus teaches from the law and the
prophets and that means the books of the
new and the Old Testament or it's a
sword with two edges that's where God
says in the mouth of at least two
witnesses his word is established and so
these two witnesses that were under
attack it was really the birth of
atheism that happened with the French
Revolution and I know I'm just I really
don't have time to go through all of
chapter 11 but you look at the
characteristics of the two witnesses and
by the way the two witnesses that you
find in Revelation chapter 11 are also
found in the book of Zechariah
I think it's chapter 4 and it says these
are two lampstands by the throne of God
well the reason they're called lamp's
thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path it says these two
witnesses can call down plagues from
heaven well you got plagues in the Old
Testament you got plagues in the New
Testament these two witnesses it says
can stop the rain it says they stopped
the rain and there was famine in the Old
Testament and there was a famine in the
days of a goddess
in the book of Acts in the New Testament
so it's really talking about the Word of
God now I hope all that rambling made a
little bit of sense yeah so it would be
the old and the New Testament yeah I've
got a book I can send you on that for
free would you like it if you tell me no
it'll hurt my feelings because I wrote
it so you gotta say oh yeah yeah I want
two of them so the book is called the
two witnesses and if you call the
resource line 808 three five six seven
four seven we'll send you a copy of the
two witnesses thank you very much for
your call and with that we're gonna go
to Line six here and talk to frits in
Orlando Florida Fritz you're on the air
with Bible answers live hi buster dog hi
my question comes from Leviticus 25
verses 44 to 46 where he talks about
slavery okay I came across the passage
and I'm not very clear on I mean this is
it justifying slavery can you just put
that in context with me well you're
gonna find let me just answer the bigger
question you're going to find that in
the laws of Moses God made laws to
protect people in very tough times
God does not approve of slavery but the
whole world had slaves back then and God
made laws to protect the slaves even in
the ten commandments it says they were
required to let their slave rest every
week and they weren't to beat their
slave and if they beat their slave and
they injured their slave there was
punishment for that God does not approve
a polygamy but God in the Levitical law
made laws to protect an extra wife it
says you cannot do certain things you
have to treat them all fairly and you
can't deny the firstborn of one wife if
you love the other one more and and
that's back in a time when men would go
to war and they'd be decimated and there
just weren't enough husbands and the
Hebrews had a law that if if a brother
died his brother was to take his wife
and family into the home and take care
of him so
the laws remain for the protection of
people in some very tough times but God
does not approve a polygamy and he does
not approve of slavery and you can see
that even more clearly when you get to
the New Testament you read the book of
Philemon Philemon Paul writes to a
runaway slave and it's a very it's one
chapter read that and it'll give you
some insights on that does that help a
little hey Thank You Franz appreciate
your question and we're gonna talk to
line number seven here talking to
Justyna
from Quincy California is that my saying
that right just dinner you're on the air
yes just being an Anderson hey thank you
for calling we got three minutes before
the break you got a question yes I do so
I went to church and you know I'm
growing up in church and we talk about
false prophets that we're going to run
across the mean times but recently some
of my Christian friends were talking
about like actual prophets and the end
times that are going to spring up and
like yeah speak the truth to the world
and I never knew that there were going
to be more prophets I thought that all
the prophets in the Bible were the
prophets and that was it like I didn't
know they were gonna be modern-day
prophets so could you talk about that
I'm kind of complete great question I'm
so glad you asked that because there's
so much misunderstanding first of all we
got to be careful about false prophets
the first thing Jesus says in Matthew 24
when he talks about the last days he
says beware of false Christ's and false
prophets but he wouldn't say beware of
false prophets unless they were also
going to be true prophets or he would
have said beware of anyone who claims to
be a prophet and if you go to first
Corinthians chapter 14 Paul talks about
prophecy in the gift of prophecy as one
of the gifts in the church and he talks
about you know there are pastors
prophets evangelists and so all the
other gifts that Paul identifies we
still believer in the church today and
so we've got to be careful about saying
that God now can no longer give a person
the gift of prophecy every time
historically when God did something
significant he spoke through a prophet
you know before the flood he had Noah
and before the Exodus he had Moses and
before the Babylonian captain
yet Isaiah and Jeremiah and before Jesus
he had John the Baptist well it should
make sense that before the second coming
of Jesus they'd be something let me give
you a verse Malachi chapter 4 I just
quoted behold I send you Elijah the
Prophet before the Great and dreadful
day of the Lord and he will turn the
hearts of the father's to the children
in the hearts of the children to the
father's now John the Baptist came in
the spirit and power of Elijah just
before Jesus but Jesus said John has
come or Elijah has come and jesus said
Elijah will come meaning there will be
an additional example of that now I
trust you're still listening
I got a listen I want to send you on
does God inspire prophets it's free you
call our resource line 808 three five
six seven four seven and we'd like to
send you that free lesson does God
inspire prophets just in a and you'll be
blessed by that friends don't go
anywhere we've just gotten our momentum
for the second half a Bible answers live
call in with your questions 800 god says
we'll be back right after the break
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts has impacted manage praise
God for amazing facts amazing facts
actually did have an impact is full
process getting to Miriam today I began
reading the Bible when I got baptized
into a seventh dead I realized that
there had to be more of the lie that
he's really doing that is the life that
he's coming this message was so powerful
I swear he knows amazing facts more than
45 years of proclaiming God's message
around the world and in the logo pops
across amazing facts presents I've
listened to a lot of different ministers
but he was this was the first time that
he's actually saying something where I
had to grab my Bible actually pick it up
and I've never heard this before let me
let me look through and find this that I
just couldn't get enough and so I
started doing Bible study every single
one of these guys started being changed
including myself my question was why did
that happen to me God the Lord was able
to reach out and I actually saw him as a
father I lost everything and that was
when I realized that it was gone missing
in my life I went to a prophecy seminar
which knocked me out this message was so
powerful and so irrefutable
I just went this is real this is this is
amazing
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 r so thankful
you are we're gonna start taking some
questions from our Facebook callers here
in the future typically they have to
call in to the radio program but it'd be
nice every program to take a couple that
are texted in to the page but I am
Manning the program tonight pastor Ross
is on vacation but we're going to go
back to the phones now talk with Jerry
in Medford Oregon Jerry you are on the
air with Bible answers live yes pastor
good afternoon or evening it's always a
pleasure to talk to you likewise I
during the wait another question came to
mind that is more important and then the
one I presented to the individual who
received my call
so can I switch questions all right
we're gonna just we're gonna go for it
and see what happens okay
concerning ties there there's a lot of
Christian organization the SDA church is
one of them that have organizations that
aid homeless orphans and
and then there are other known ones in
many US cities that provide shelters for
derelict and so on people that are
letting down on their luck so my
question is is it is it acceptable to
give your tithe to these organizations
who have this dual mission of
ministering and providing humanitarian
aid to people orphans in need
alright good question I believe that
tithe biblically is to be restricted for
the proclamation of the gospel and then
you have offerings in the Bible the
priest Paul says in the New Testament as
well as in the old it says they receive
tithes and the idea was that people who
had dedicated were dedicated to
full-time ministry did not have to take
up a job where you know they they were
so busy supporting themselves and their
family that they couldn't be involved in
full-time teaching and exposition of the
word in the times of the greatest
prosperity in Israel spiritually the
tithes were brought to the storehouse
distributed to the Levites who were
ministering to the people in the
synagogues throughout the Land of Israel
during the time of Hezekiah Jehoshaphat
some of it was happening during the time
of Samuel during times of apostasy they
neglected it
the Levites all went took jobs the
teaching of the people fell apart and
there was usually moral decline tithe
really should go to that all frames is
different from tithe and if you read in
Malachi chapter 3 talks about tithe and
offering tithe was 1/10 offerings were
something above and beyond that and you
know we do have a free study guide we'll
be happy to send you a free copy of that
Jerry and it's called in god we trust' a
play on the phrase we find on our money
in god we trust'
goes through all the Bible teachings on
tithe and how it should be applied and
if you want a free copy call 885 6 7 4 7
these are beautifully illustrated color
studies and they are very thorough and
we've just reprinted them all 808 3 5 6
7 4
and we'll send you one of those we got
several callers I'm very excited to hear
that and see that we're gonna talk next
to Angela
and in British Columbia Angela you're on
the air with Bible answers live hi thank
you so much for taking my call and for
your ministry
it's a pleasure I was wondering about
smoking can you
I know I've quit before and I used
chantix but are there other ways yeah to
do it well I'm glad that you're wanting
to quit and you know what the Lord will
bless you I smoked for several years my
mother smoked my father smoked my
grandfather smoked and hiatus guy kind
of grew up inhaling nicotine I became
convicted after I became a Christian
that my body is a temple of the Holy
Spirit I read on the cigarette packs
this is going to kill you I read in the
Ten Commandments don't kill that would
include yourself and I thought I don't
think this is a glorifying God I believe
God wants me to quit I tried to quit and
it's like Mark Twain said quitting is
easy I did it a hundred times
staying quit was a challenge now what
did it for me and you know I am NOT
against a person using some kind of
medicinal help put without it I finally
did and what did it for me was just an
overwhelming sense of the sacrifice that
Jesus made for me and that my body was a
temple of the Holy Spirit and one day I
threw away my cigarettes 37 years ago
no 41 years ago I'm getting old and I
haven't smoked since I haven't put one
in my mouth and so I believe God can
give you the victory now it was tough I
mean I don't want to pretend I didn't
struggle those first couple of days were
real tough then the week or two after
that was hard but not as bad and then as
a month went by it's still think of it
but it wasn't bad
kind of like the waves kept getting
smaller and further apart until I don't
think about it at all anymore so if you
know you're not born smoking you learn
to do it and you have to unlearn it and
it just takes some time and you can get
it behind you think of all the money
save and it's it's good for your witness
but I I did quit for a year in three
months and then it kind of just and then
you pick one started with one right yeah
yeah and how did you feel after you
started again didn't you feel rotten for
doing really bad yeah you know how good
you're gonna feel if you stop better
than I do now do you have kids
I have a daughter yeah that's an even
better reason hey could I pray with you
real quick Angela yeah I believe in
something called the five minute plan
and let me tell you what the five minute
plan is first of all do you believe God
wants you to quit smoking yes do you
believe God will help you do what he
wants you to do oh yes I do then all
you've got left to do is to take the
first step and ask him and if you like
I'll pray with you right now and then
I'm gonna encourage you if you've got
any cigarettes you go throw them out and
see what God does for you and that's the
way it works you know you'll live
through it and so it's just a question
of in your mind in your heart and God
can give you the power
father in heaven I just want to lift up
my prayer right now in Angela's behalf
and others who may be listening that are
struggling with smoking or one of these
other habits and help them now believe
in your power to break the chains just
as you said Peter free from prison you
can break the chains and the habits that
bind us Jesus came to save us from our
sins and to give us new life and new
health and I pray you'll bless her and
bless her in her body bless her in her
witness and help her to know that your
spirit and angels are right there to
encourage her and be free from this we
pray in Jesus name Amen amen thank you
so much pastor Doug absolutely you can
make it and you know I've got a study
guide I'll send you a free copy and it's
called God's free health plan it'll
encourage you God's free health plan
it's called just dial the number eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can also read it for free at
amazing facts dot o-r-g
well thank you for that call and we're
gonna move on now and talk to Michael in
Mount Pleasant is that Michigan hello hi
Michael thanks for calling wow that's
pretty good
not bad I have a question I just talked
to a friend today on messenger and we
did you know video chat and at the end
of our you know conversation um where's
this I don't know if there's a brother
it doesn't matter if it's her brother or
no but um she says something to her
brother and then she says I'm gay and
that's when I stopped talking to all I'm
like oh that's my a normal reaction when
they share about someone you know in
that sense of minds and my question is
it wrong to have people that are you
know that laid both nose in was a sense
is that a wrong thing to have say is it
wrong for them to what I couldn't hear
the last thing he said is it wrong to
like it they just seem like mailings you
know is it wrong to have them as a
friend oh we've been crying well that's
that let's ask this question did just a
couple of different kinds of friends one
is you want to you want to befriend
people so you can be a witness you got
to be careful about being intimate
friends where the person that is going
to drag you down spiritually but Jesus
is a friend of sinners Jesus spent time
witnessing two harlots and publicans and
we need to build relationships with
sinners so that we can share the Word of
God with them see what I'm saying it's
one thing to have a relationship with a
person to be a witness but you don't
want to walk in their ways in other
words I will try to encourage a person
who's struggling with drinking and I'll
be their friend I'll try and help them
but I'm not going to go to the bar and
give them a Bible study in the bar yeah
so you got to know how you can be a
friend and be a witness but don't let
them pull you and your thinking in the
wrong direction
so you know Christian means to choose
friends that will also encourage them in
holiness but we've got to have
relationships with the lost or how are
else are we going to reach them all
right I just you know I love to help
news I can't actually had that problem
so love doing everybody
you know yeah you want to show love to
everybody and you can if you have a real
friend you know I've got friends that
struggle with you know homosexuality and
and they know where I stand and they
know I love them and I want to be their
friend I don't support what they're
doing but you've got to show people you
care about them and as individuals and
you value them but at the same time
whatever it is whether it's
homosexuality or you know I had a friend
that was he was always living you with
all kinds of I'll just say moral
indiscretions and he'd tell me about it
and say look I don't hear about that
that's wrong and you know I'd be his
friend I try and encourage him but he'd
also know I did not approve of what he
was doing so that's the balance I think
we're looking for is loving people
having relationships showing you value
them witnessing to them and yet not
walking with the ungodly as it says in
Psalm one thank you for your call
Michael and we're gonna take another
call and talk next to Patti
who's calling from Carmichael California
I know where that is hello Patti Happy
Easter
likewise thank you my question I was
reading Exodus we were studying on
Christian radio station and I came
across the stanzas that just blew me out
of the water which is exodus four
stanzas 24 through 26
could you please yeah was God going to
kill Moses and what in the world is that
all about those three little things
let me let me read that to you it says
and it came to pass on the way to the
encampment that the Lord met him Moses
and sought to kill him then sapore his
wife took a sharp stone and cut off the
foreskin of her son and cast it at Moses
feet and said surely you are a husband
of blood to me or a bloody man and so he
the angel let him go and she said you
are a husband of blood because of the
circumcision now the the way that most
commentators understand that is God had
just called Moses
to be the spiritual leader to lead this
nation out of slavery and yet Moses had
two sons with Zipporah and he hadn't
circumcised one of them oh and supporter
evidently thought you know why would you
do that that's bloody that's barbaric
and he said well this is the Covenant
that God made and they had some kind of
family argument between the husband and
the wife so when the Lord God had
continued to convict Moses you need to
take care of this you need to take care
of this and he's getting ready to cross
into Egypt and and got said look you
can't do what I've called you to do and
unless you obey and you're consistent
and you have to decide am I your Lord or
is your wife your Lord and so there was
a I guess there's a little family
dispute there Oh
and so God the same way the angel of the
Lord met Balaam when he was on the way
to do something he shouldn't do God met
Moses and finally Zipporah gave in and
she they circumcise the the boy and he
went on his way with his mission that
began the Exodus so yes absolutely I
appreciate that and I hope that makes a
make some sense and that is a good
question people reading through the
Bible run into that and they go what is
that all about all right with that we're
gonna go and talk next to Ken in Orlando
Florida ken you're on the air with Bible
answers live hey sir
hi thank you for calling yeah listen I'm
just a little confused and Matthew 24
when Jesus was talking to disciples and
he was given them the signs to look for
dealing with the second coming why is it
that he would do that when you know the
rapture would occur first and they
wouldn't even see that day well now
maybe maybe it's not happening exactly
like that there are three views among
Christians about the sequence of the
rapture and the rapture means to be
caught up some believe everyone almost
Christians believe there's going to be a
tribulation time of trouble right the
question is does the time of trouble
happen before the rapture
does it happen after or does the rapture
happen in the middle of it and some post
post mid-trib pre-trip yeah and that's
the bre v8
I am in the old school and when I say
the old school I mean I'm in the same
school as Charles Spurgeon and John
Wesley and Martin Luther and a lot of
the Reformers that the time of trouble
happens before anything if you would
like I'll tell you real quick why it
says that he that endures to the end
will be saved indoors whoa well you've
got the the plagues and the tribulation
that are happening the Bible tells us
Paul says it is through much tribulation
we enter the kingdom of God God is
coming for a church without spot or
wrinkle and he gets rid of the spots and
the wrinkles through the hot water hot
iron and Peter said do not be amazed at
the fiery trials that will try you as
though some strange thing has happened
so God did not save the Israelites from
the plagues of Egypt he saved them
through the plagues and the seven last
plagues in Revelation are the
tribulation so I've got a book on that
and I'd be happy to send your free copy
but there's a whole lot of a whole lot
of sincere Christians on all the sides
of this issue I don't want to you know
condemn anyone that doesn't agree with
me but I'm I've got the old-fashioned
view the the idea through the
tribulation yeah and God protect us I'm
not worried about it it says that that's
why it says in Psalm 91 no plague will
come now your dwelling a thousand will
fall at your right hand but it will not
come nigh unto thee so there's a lot of
promises we don't need to worry about
the plagues in the tribulation but I do
think that we're in the world and let me
give you one more verse Daniel chapter
12 it says at that time Michael will
stand up the Great Prince that stands
for the children of thy people and there
will be a time of trouble such as there
never has been ever since there was a
nation even unto that time and at that
time thy people are delivered every one
who is found written in the book
so Jesus refers to that great time of
trouble such as there never has been in
Matthew 24 and it says that's when God's
people are delivered
so take a look at the phone makes a lot
of sense yeah let's take a look at the
book that I'm gonna save and send you
and it's called anything but secret
anything but secret it's free call 883
five six seven four seven Ken that's 808
then you're welcome thank you very much
for your your question and with that
we're gonna go and talk next to Roger
we're just going down the line here
Roger and you're on the air yes sir
serious question I'm how how does the
Lord give us strength to not commit
adultery well jesus said blessed are the
pure in heart if you read in the book of
Job job said I've made a covenant with
my eyes why should i behold a young
woman because he was married and so it's
a question of trying to keep focus okay
but what is your wife doesn't feel the
same way and it's actually what is she
has some problems of remote that that
doesn't let her get ourselves to me
because we're both Christian and we're
both trying to do what's right I'm well
that is very tough but let me let's talk
about it for a minute if if a man is
married and and he and his wife they get
you know normal marriage and suppose the
wife then has a health problem where
they can no longer have intimacy for
whatever reason does that give the man
the right then to violate the marriage
and go find someone else
I say no that's a terrible burden and
but you know God sometimes gives us
trials and we pray for grace Paul said
he had a thorn in the flesh and he
prayed three times that God would take
it away and Satan was buffeting him and
God said no my strength is made perfect
in weakness so you know you pray for
healing you pray that things would
improve but you know there's no excuse
for a man or a woman to violate the
marriage vows and commit adultery if for
some reason things are not working out
now the bible does say that a man or
woman in a marriage does not have a
right to
with hold indefinitely intimacy the
Bible says a man's body belongs to the
wife and the wife's body belongs to the
man and you should if you want to
separate and agree to separate and and
fast and pray well that's fine they said
then come back together again lest you
be tempted for your your inconsistency
and so you know but otherwise people say
that um in marriage the bed is undefiled
so I hope that helps a little bit and I
do have a book that talks about marriage
divorce and remarriage Roger will be
happy to send you a copy of that gonna
try and squeeze in a couple more calls
here talk to David is that Kona Hawaii
David morality air with Bible answers
live yes pastor Doug I've been studying
with a great friend of mine pastor
Diamond Garcia here in Hawaii and we
were going over this subject on the
Sabbath and I was reading in Isaiah 66
where he showed me that that we would
keep the Sabbath in heaven and so I also
saw that in that same text had mentioned
that that will be keeping the new moons
as well and I'm wondering what that
means and if we would be keeping the
festivals in heaven in the future yeah
that's it by the way say hello to my
friend diamond and I wish I was with you
right now in Kona I've been there many
times but we're reading from Isaiah
chapter 66 verse 22 let me read it to
you for as the new heavens and the new
earth which I will make shall remain
before me says the Lord so shall your
descendants in your name remain and it
will come to pass it from one new moon
to another and one Sabbath to another
all flesh will come and worship before
me says the Lord now the moon right now
is it's on a cycle of a little more than
what is it there's a little less than
twenty seven days the lunar cycle I
think that the whole world and the lunar
cycle has been damaged by sin and the
flood we are not going to have winter in
heaven the earth right now rotates on
its axis it was a 20 degrees and that's
why you get the swing of the seasons I
think the moon in heaven is going to
line up
quickly with every 28 days which is
every fourth Sabbath is also going to be
a new moon so every new moon will land
on a Sabbath you see what I'm saying
so the weeks and the months we'll all be
coordinated and and every Sabbath we're
going to come and worship before the
Lord every fourth Sabbath it'll be a new
moon it'll be like a high time to
worship before the Lord but I don't
think it's telling us to keep the feast
days because the Bible Sabbath goes back
to creation before sin you got Genesis 2
chapter 2 there's no mention made of the
New Moon's until the Levitical law is
given no I don't believe so I think is
saying that from week to week and month
the month because though the new months
will always line up with every fourth
week right okay well thank you so much
and I'll tell you yeah please do that
and thank you so much for your call all
right gonna talk next to Liz calling
from San Diego is that right Liz you're
on the air with Bible answers live hi
didn't you for this opportunity I wanted
to ask question about animals and animal
cruelty just like I'm seeing so much
suffering and animals and physically
like I don't know about emotionally but
physically there definitely are
suffering and they're so depending on
humans and as far as I know like God
doesn't say that they will be in heaven
and why's it like this I mean God is in
our loving and just well why he allows
animals who did not spend to suffer it's
a story all right let's let me dive into
that before we just got a couple minutes
left I want to try and give you answer
first of all your questions a good
question but we could also ask why do
children suffer not just animals because
of a bad decision sometimes there are
innocent people that suffer because of
the decision of Adam and Eve you and I
are suffering right we didn't I mean I
didn't no one ever asked me about the
forbidden fruit you know I was born in
this world
of sin and suffering my brother was born
with a deadly disease and and he died at
35 and he didn't do anything to deserve
that
and these animals I mean God loves the
animals and Adam named the animals and
he was supposed to care for them
whenever we do wrong it not only hurts
us but there's a ripple effect it
ricochets and it bounces off those
around us and even the creatures and the
creation so it grieves God now there are
going to be animals in heaven God
created them he loves them and you read
that in heaven the lion will lay down
with the ox and a bear and a wolf and a
lamb we're gonna all feed together and
so the Bible in prophecy paints a
beautiful picture of heaven as a
paradise once again where the animals
are living peacefully with each other
and with man and so the sooner Jesus
comes the sooner we'll have that new
heaven that new earth and and you know I
I will tell you there is a verse in the
Bible lizz it says a righteous man
regards the life of his beast but the
tender mercies of the wicked are cruel
and I forget the verse but it's in
Proverbs so God wants us to care about
the animals I apologize if we didn't get
to your question tonight friends and
want to again greet in thank those who
have tuned in on Facebook we it looks
like we got thousands of people that are
joining us on our Facebook feed as well
as our radio and satellite radio
audience around the country I want to
remind you and you know it's that time
of year we're thinking about the
sacrifice and the resurrection of Jesus
this ministry is a hundred percent a
faith ministry we don't receive any
subsidy from any corporation or
denomination amazing facts since its
inception has only been supported by
people who listen if you've been blessed
if you've learned anything we sure would
appreciate hearing from you and you can
make a donation keep us on the air just
simply go to amazing facts dot o-r-g
and it's a click away god bless you
listening friends we got some important
announcements to close off this
broadcast and we will talk and study his
word together again next
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
well you're hit with something new your
marriage your job your health you could
look to the stars
but they don't know the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts
it's 27 personal study guides leave you
on a life-changing journey get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore com can't get enough amazing
facts Bible study you don't have to wait
until next week to enjoy more truth
filled programming visit the amazing
facts media library at aft vor G at aft
vor G you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G did you know that Noah
was present at the birth of Abraham okay
maybe he wasn't in the room but he was
alive and probably telling stories about
his floating zoo from the creation of
the world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word visit our
website at WWF AG 0 RG and sign up for
our free Bible study course and make
sure to check out our online bookstore
at AF bookstore comm which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 macing facts dot o RG